hey guys my name is justin i'm dan and
it is almost the end of august
but here's a brand new gaming news
episode for your new thursday
wednesday it's wednesday it is wednesday
just before we keep going thank you so
much for all your feedback on the
thumbnails you might have seen they've
changed now to have gamespot news in the
logo
so you can find us more easily let us
know if you need uh anything else
obviously not
money no like anything related to the
show related to the show
anyway here's news
first up if you're a fan of leaks today
is a good day for you
as it sounds like destiny 2 dlc info has
arrived before the games even come out
if you guys want to avoid spoilers on
this one i'll put down the time code to
get past this story if you want to skip
through but for now here's what we know
a report from kotaku indicates that the
first dlc pack will add a patrol zone on
mercury a social space and a storyline
centered around osiris the curse of
osiris will apparently revolve around
the exiled warlock osiris
known for his zealous studies of the
darkness it sounds like you'll be tasked
with saving him from the vex
osiris briefly featured in the original
game where players could compete in the
trials of osiris in the hopes of gaining
access to the lighthouse on mercury to
receive rewards
destiny 2's dlc will apparently feature
the lighthouse much more prominently as
a fully-fledged social space you'll also
be able to head down to mercury for
patrol missions and quests
no word yet on whether the curse of
osiris will include a raid
what it'll cost or when it'll be
released but as always stay tuned to us
on youtube and gamespot and when we know
you will
too we all make mistakes i mean one time
i said bethesda made mass effect when it
was actually bioware and i got all the
way through unedited news until i
realized i'd said it so i had to go back
and reshoot it
but luckily i caught it before it went
live something sony probably should have
done with september's playstation plus
games of which they got
all wrong before they corrected them
here's what you're actually getting in
september
on ps4 you'll get infamous second sun
and strike vector ex
infamous second sun is fantastic and
hopefully that means an announcement
about what sucker punch are working on
is coming soon please hurry up and tell
me what you're doing sucker punch
ps3 owners can get their paws on
handball 16
and truck racer while vita owners can
sink into we're doomed and hatterfull
boyfriend
if you want to date pigeons on the big
screen you can as both powerful
boyfriend and we're doomed are available
on ps4 via crossbuy
let us know what you're looking forward
to picking up in that comment section
below
finally nintendo have revealed a whole
bunch of indie games that are on their
way to switch and i really do mean a
whole bunch there's tons including a new
no more heroes game
and a new super meat boy no more heroes
travis strikes again takes place seven
years after the original no more heroes
and will see protagonist travis
touchdown sucked into a phantom game
console
inside he'll need to defeat six games
and their bosses in order to escape
the trailer is exactly what you'd expect
from the man who confused a translator
into silence at the nintendo switch
reveal event
interestingly the game will be a
collaboration with other notable indie
developers and grasshopper manufacturer
there's even a cameo of hotline miami in
the trailer you can check out the full
trailer right here on gamespot
elsewhere in the nindy's summer 2017
showcase we got a look at super meat boy
forever a sequel to the indie hit that
will feature levels that get
progressively harder the more times you
complete them yep sounds like super meat
boy there was also announcements for
steamworld dig 2
shovel knight king of cards the final
dlc pack for shovel knight and kentucky
route 0 tv edition along with a heap of
others you can check out the full list
of announcements and their expected
release dates over on gamespot
that is everything we've got for you
today do leave us your thoughts and
feelings on today's stories down in that
comment section and come have a chat to
us
if you feel so inclined we'll be back
same time tomorrow
please hurry up and tell me what you're
doing sucker punch
suck a punch please you're my favorite
game developer
you guys make good games that i like to
play they made two games you liked
incorrect they've made like seven games
that i really like
sly raccoon one through three fantastic
infamous one through three
four seven so seven games